♪ ♪
>> Dana: THE WHITE HOUSE AND
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS TOOK SOME
HEAVY CRITICISM FOR STATES
REOPENING THAT NOW BLUE STATES
ARE STARTING TO FOLLOW SUIT WITH
VERY LITTLE PUSHBACK.
CALIFORNIA, NEW YORK, COLORADO,
AND WASHINGTON ALL SLOWLY
STARTING TO LIFT RESTRICTIONS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ARGUING THAT
IT’S NECESSARY.
>> IF THEY HELD PEOPLE ANY
LONGER WITH THIS SHUTDOWN,
YOU’RE GOING TO LOSE PEOPLE THAT
WAY TOO AND YOU ALREADY HAVE,
I’M SURE.
BETWEEN DRUG ABUSE AND I MEAN
THEY SAY SUICIDE, A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS.
THERE’S NO WIN.
THERE IS NO GREAT WIN ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER.
>> Dana: JESSE, I DON’T REALLY
UNDERSTAND HOW REOPENING HAS
BECOME A REPUBLICAN VERSUS
DEMOCRAT ISSUE, SINCE THE VIRUS
DOESN’T DISCRIMINATE.
AND THE LOCKDOWN DIDN’T
DISCRIMINATE.
IT AFFECTS ALL OF US.
HELP ME UNDERSTAND THAT.
>> Jesse: GLADLY.
WE HAVE COVERED THIS PRETTY
METHODICALLY FOR THE LAST TWO
MONTHS AND HERE’S WHAT I’VE
OBSERVED.
WHEN A DEMOCRAT GOVERNOR LOCKS
DOWN, THEY GET PRAISED.
WHEN THEY OPEN THINGS BACK UP,
THEY ARE IGNORED.
WHEN A REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR LOCKS
DOWN, THEY ARE IGNORED AND WHEN
THEY OPEN THINGS BACK UP, THEY
ARE ATTACKED.
THAT TELLS ME TWO THINGS.
THE MEDIA LOVES DEMOCRATS AND
THE MEDIA LOVES LOCKDOWNS.
THERE YOU GO, DANA.
DEDUCTIVE REASONING.
THINK ABOUT IT.
HIM YOU HAD GOVERNOR KEMP IN
GEORGIA WHO BASICALLY SAID WE
ARE GOING TO OPEN THINGS UP,
NEARLY TWO WEEKS AGO.
GUESS WHAT HAPPENED?
NOT EVERYBODY DIED IN THE WORLD
DIDN’T COME TO AN END.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, THE NUMBER
OF CASES HAVE SLOWLY DECLINED IN
TWO WEEKS.
THE SAME THING WITH FLORIDA.
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS, HE HAD A
PRETTY LIBERAL BEACH POLICY AND
COUNTY BY COUNTY LOCKDOWN
APPROACH.
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO BE THE
NEXT NEW YORK, BIG ELDERLY
POPULATION.
DIDN’T HAPPEN.
SO OBVIOUSLY IT’S POLITICIZED,
AND I THINK WE ALL KNOW WHY.
>> Dana: AFTER IT I KNOW.
I WAS BEING A LITTLE FACETIOUS.
I’M REALLY NOT THAT -- I WAS
TRYING TO MAKE THE POINT THAT IT
REALLY IS AFFECTING EVERYBODY
AND THE REOPENING IS AFFECTING
EVERYBODY AS WELL.
IN SOME PLACES IT’S GOING TO BE
QUITE SLOW, AND THERE’S EVEN
SOME BUSINESSES, LIKE
RESTAURANTS, WHO ARE MAY BE
LIMITED TO 25% CAPACITY WHO
THINK "I CAN’T MAKE A PROFIT
WITH 25% CAPACITY," SO THEY
MIGHT NOT OPEN AT ALL.
>> Greg: THIS IS WHERE YOU
DON’T GO DOWN PARTY LINES,
IDEOLOGY.
IT’S ADULT VERSUS CHILDREN.
THIS IS AN ISSUE IN WHICH YOU
ARE FACING SUPREMELY ADULT
QUESTIONS.
ADULTS, UNLIKE CHILDREN, HAVE TO
DISCUSS RISK AND BENEFITS EVERY
DAY OF THEIR DECISIONS.
CHILDREN DON’T.
I HAVE A NEW LAW.
I CALL IT THE SC CUP LAW, THE
REIGNING QUEEN OF ADDING TO A
CONVERSATION.
WHEN CHRIS CHRISTIE SAYS FUTURE
DECISIONS REGARDING LOCKDOWNS
ARE GOING TO CARRY A RISK OF
DEATH, YOU WILL SEE THE COWARDLY
GAWKER WITH NO SKIN IN THE GAME
WHO MAKES NO ADULT DECISIONS
WILL SAY, BUT PEOPLE WILL DIE.
YOU ARE INSENSITIVE TO DEATH,
AND YOU SHOULD GO TO A CROWDED
PLACE AND FEED THE HUNGRY
BECAUSE YOU DON’T CARE.
SO THAT’S THE CHILDLIKE ANSWER
EVERY TIME.
I THINK WE CAN SAVE OUR VIEWERS
A LOT OF TIME IF WE JUST CANCEL
OUT THESE OBVIOUS POINTS LIKE
ADULTS KNOW THAT EVERY DEATH IS
TOO MUCH.
WE KNOW THAT.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT OPENING UP IS
GOING TO INCREASE RISK.
WE ALSO ACCEPT AND SHARE THE
RISK EVERY DAY WITH DIFFERENT
ACTIONS.
IF YOUR ARGUMENT STILL LIVES IN
THAT TERRITORY, YOU ARE A CHILD,
AND YOU SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED AT
THE ADULT TABLE WHEN WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT THESE DECISIONS.
SO IF YOU SAY THAT THERE IS A
RISK, THE MEDIA WILL ACCUSE YOU
OF MURDER NO MATTER WHAT BECAUSE
THEY ARE CHILDREN.
WHEN THE STATES REOPEN AND THE
LEADERS ARE TAKING A CALCULATED
RISK, BLUE OR RED STATES, WE
HAVE TO GIVE THEM THE LEEWAY AND
NOT ACCUSE THEM OF MURDER
BECAUSE THAT’S INFANTILE BECAUSE
WE KNOW, WE ARE ADULTS.
WE HAVE LIVED IN THESE LIVES.
WE UNDERSTAND RISK AND BENEFITS.
DO NOT LISTEN TO THE CHILDREN.
>> Dana: JUAN, WHAT ABOUT THE
FACTORS OF LOT OF MOVING OF THE
GOALPOSTS MAYBE THE LEFT AND THE
MEDIA IN SOME CASES WHERE THE
GOAL OF FLATTENING THE CURVE WAS
SO THAT YOU DIDN’T OVERWHELM THE
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS.
IF THAT GOAL WAS ACHIEVED AND I
ARE GOING TO REOPEN, THE GOAL IS
NOT TO SHUT DOWN UNTIL WE HAVE A
VACCINE, RIGHT?
>> Juan: NO, NOT AT ALL.
I THINK THE GOAL IS, AS YOU ARE
SAYING, TO MAKE SURE HOSPITALS
MAINTAIN CAPACITY.
ALSO, AND I THINK THIS IS REALLY
CRITICAL, SPEAKING AT THE ADULT
TABLE, IF I MIGHT, THAT WE HAVE
PUBLIC TRUST.
YOU CAN REOPEN THINGS BUT IF THE
PUBLIC DOESN’T TRUST THAT THEY
WON’T GET SICK, AND THAT’S
NECESSARILY MEANING THEY WILL BE
HOSPITALIZED OR THAT THEY WILL
DIE BUT THAT THEY WON’T GET
SICK, THEY WON’T TRUST YOU AND
COME OUT TO YOUR RESTAURANT.
I THINK I SAW NUMBERS TODAY, 80%
SAY THEY WON’T GO TO A MOVIE.
70% NOT WILLING TO GO TO THE GYM
OR A RESTAURANT.
60% NOT EVEN WILLING TO GO TO A
RETAIL CLOTHING STORE.
SO I THINK YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND IT’S ABOUT
ENGENDERING PUBLIC TRUST IN
TERMS OF HOW PUBLIC LEADERS
SPEAK TO THE PEOPLE.
IF IT’S ALL CHEERLEADING, THAT’S
NOT TRUST.
>> Dana: DAGEN, DO BUSINESSES
HAVE A ROLE AS WELL?
WE TALKED TO THE STARBUCKS CEO
TODAY, FINDING MITIGATION
MEASURES TO TRY TO ENGENDER THAT
TRUST WITH CONSUMERS SO THEY
FEEL COMFORTABLE COMING INTO THE
SHOP.
>> Dagen: THEY ALREADY ARE.
THERE IS A SHAKE SHACK OPEN DOWN
THE STREET FROM HERE.
THEY ARE ABOUT PROTECTING THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND CUSTOMERS BUT I
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE KNOWN ALL ALONG AND
WE HEARD IT OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
WE MUST PROTECT THE MOST
VULNERABLE IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE MUST PROTECT THEM MOST AT
RISK.
IN TERMS OF PUBLIC TRUST, THAT’S
NOT SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED.
IN NEW YORK STATE.
NEW YORK STATE IN MARCH MANDATED
THAT NURSING HOMES HAD TO TAKE
COVID-19 PATIENTS BACK IN THAT
WERE DISCHARGED FROM HOSPITALS.
TODAY WE FOUND OUT THAT 1700
PREVIOUSLY UNDISCLOSED DEATHS
THAT NURSING HOMES AND ADULT
CARE FACILITIES HAPPENED IN THIS
STATE.
MORE THAN 1400 ELDERLY PEOPLE
HAVE DIED FROM COVID-19 IN
NURSING HOMES SINCE MARCH 1ST.
I FIND THIS HEARTBREAKING AND
ALMOST MALICIOUS.
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE TO PEOPLE
WHO WE SHOULD HAVE CARED FOR
WITH THE GREATEST HEART AND THE
GREATEST HEAD AND IT’S
DISGUSTING.
>> Dana: AND I READ THAT IF
THAT WAS YOUR WIFE OR HUSBAND,
YOUR GRANDMOTHER, YOUR MOTHER,
YOUR SISTER, THEY HAD ABOUT
ANOTHER TEN YEARS TO LIVE ON
AVERAGE.
FOR THOSE WHO GOT COVID-19 AND
WENT BACK TO THE NURSING HOME.
>> Dagen: AND THE STATE WAS
WARNED BY DOCTORS ABOUT THE